a tiny but horrible alien is standing at
the top of the eiffel tower so this is
where the tiny but horrible alien is
which is 324 meters tall and they label
that the height of the eiffel tower and
threatening to destroy the city of paris
a man in black or i guess a or a men in
black agent i was about to say she maybe
should be a man in black a men in black
agent is standing at ground level 54
meters across the eiffel square so 54
meters from i guess you could say the
center of the base of the eiffel tower
aiming his laser gun at the alien so
this is him aiming the laser gun
at what angle should the agent shoot his
laser gun round your answer if necessary
to two decimal places so if we construct
a right triangle here and we can
so the height of this right triangle is
324 meters this width right over here is
54 meters it is a right triangle what
they're really asking us is what is the
angle what is this angle
what is this angle right over here
and they've given us two pieces of
information they gave us the side that
is opposite the angle and they've given
us the side that is adjacent to the
angle
so what trig function deals with
opposite and adjacent and to remind
ourselves we can write like i always
like to do soca
and these are really by definition so
you just kind of have to know this and
so katoa helps us
sine is opposite over hypotenuse cosine
is adjacent over hypotenuse tangent is
opposite over adjacent so we can say
that the tangent
we can write that the tangent of theta
the tangent of theta is equal to the
length of the opposite side
324 meters
meters over the length of the adjacent
side
over 50
over 54 meters now you might say well
okay that's fine no so what what angle
gives the when i take its tangent gives
me 324 over 54. well for this it will
probably be useful to use a calculator
and the way that we'd use a calculator
is we would use the inverse tan function
so
we would we could rewrite this as we're
going to take the inverse tangent and
sometimes it's written as tangent kind
of this negative 1 superscript
so the inverse tangent of tan of theta
is going to be equal to the inverse
tangent of 324
324 over 54
over
54. and just to be clear what is this
inverse tangent this literally says
what is this will return what is the
angle that when i take the tangent of it
gives me 324 over 54.
this says what is the tan what is the
angle that when i take the tangent of it
gives me tangent of theta so this right
over here is just going to this just
simplifies to
theta
theta is the angle that when you get the
tangent of it gets you tangent of theta
and so we get theta is equal to tangent
inverse tangent of 324
324 over 54. once again this inverse
tangent thing you might find confusing
but all this is saying is over here
we're saying tangent of some angle is
324 over 54. this is just saying is my
angle is whatever angle i need so that
when i take the tangent of it i get 324
over 54. it's how we will solve for
theta
so let's get our calculator out
and let's say that we want our answer in
degrees and actually they should well
i'm just going to assume that they they
want our answer in degree so let me make
sure my calculator is actually in degree
mode so i'll go to the second mode right
over here and actually it's in radian
mode right now so let me make sure i'm
in degree mode to get my answer in
degrees
now let me exit out of here and let me
just type in the inverse tangent so it's
in this yellow color right inverse
tangent of 324 divided by 54 is going to
be
80 point and they told us to round to
two decimal places
80.54 degrees
so theta is equal to
80.54 degrees that's the angle at which
you should shoot the gun to d to to help
defeat this horrible alien